hey everyone's Peter Brown here with
kevin van noord and we've got an
exclusive look at the intro to the
second bit of dlc for bioshock infinite
burial at sea part 2 yeah and there's a
lot to talk about it a lot to wonder
about and a lot to think what the hell
is this yeah so we should probably just
go right into it and see what we can
make out let's do it
it's going to at the end of the first
bit of DLC for burial at sea we were
left with spoilers well spoilers if
you're watching this anyway yes that's
true Booker was wrestling with a little
girl was a little daughter sister little
sister told me out of event they had
they had basically smoked and burned her
out of the vent and Elizabeth was there
next to him yeah and and then yeah and
then actually you were wrestling with a
little sister from a vent as you can see
in the background right here so sue
Chong is one of the links between
Columbia actually the main link as far
as I'm concerned between Colombia and is
rapture okay so he is a scientist who
worked with Fontaine to develop plasmids
so he's one of the minds behind plasmids
and the way he's linked Columbia is that
his technology is being taken by a by a
tear I think right by think I think yes
and in turn then if I'm led to remember
right that's how some of the Columbia
technology like the mechanical stuff
actually finds its way to rapture back
for burial is a first part yet right so
there is there is that that link there
and it looks like the the new episode is
going to be using souchong as a way of
like making this happen of getting them
back to raster and possibly of maybe
getting Elizabeth back to lumbia there's
a lot of weirdness here because there
are multiple there are multiple versions
of characters right throughout all this
so for example between the booker in the
first dlc is the booker of that universe
the elizabeth of that dlc is the
elizabeth of the universe that we played
right bioshock infinite yeah and so to
me there's a certain implication here
that that's that continues to be the
case that this elizabeth is still the
elizabeth from the last game from the
first dlc the thing is we don't know for
sure and that's the wonder of this kind
of thing or disappointment of this kind
of thing depending on how you look
they can do whatever they want with with
the excuse of what's an alternate it's
an alternate history and more missions
in whatever way we want yeah I think
that was condensed sort of was used to I
think maybe not the best effect at the
end of the original bit of DLC because
it was sort of like okay wait a minute
now this is happening hopefully I think
the second part will answer some of
those questions that aroused because I
was definitely confused and yet in
parallel see part one yeah the getting
of burial see part one was really
interesting and the takeaway of course
at the end of the first part of the dlc
is that that Booker is a Booker who in
his universe actually caused Elizabeth's
head right it's my chopped off yeah that
would have been the Elizabeth of that
particular dimension and that he gets
the loot esas to actually send him off
to rapture so that he never has to think
about any of that again yeah um so he's
you know he's basically doesn't have any
memory of comstock and so on and so
forth you know all that stuff spin
action you know wiped away right but
something the now we've got the two
versions of book which and and that's
that's interesting to me because how
exactly does that happen as far as I
know we've never had any any incidents
in these now somebody out there can
correct me if i'm wrong but i don't
remember an incidence in infinite where
there is a character that's invisible to
everybody else in the one exception not
based on your question of infinite but i
think maybe he exists in some kind of
tear maybe Elizabeth can manifest those
things meant that's true maybe she maybe
he has gone and maybe there is a tear
well we don't see the tear visual and so
that's not to say maybe its internal for
it could be yeah what's another another
interesting thing of course is that it
looks like Booker's hair is white when
he's when he's dragged away their right
and that was sort of Tamir they have to
come yeah that mirzee an and that's a
Comstock right thing you know it's it's
Booker as Comstock I just I'm hopeful
that it looks like they're sort of tying
infinite back to bioshock in a way
that's going to make a little bit more
sense if that's possible then the
original burial at sea chapter one yeah
that was a big problem actually in that
dlc little one
laughs together slap together and it
seemed like well here's the greatest
hits of different characters and we're
going to take we're just gonna bolt the
things together you know here's some
stuff from Columbia here are some stuff
from rapture we're bolting the
characters and the mechanics from this
one into the world of this one right and
they didn't necessarily make sense
together and that showed it did show in
the gameplay and the storytelling but
I'm curious you know at this point it's
it's whether or not you love it or
whether or not you think it's a train
wreck I think it's hard to look away
yeah and plus now so we're going to be
able to control Elizabeth in the second
chapter which is going to be very
interesting presumably you'll have power
over tears hopefully I think that's
pretty much everyone's expectation at
this point you would think but since
tears up to this point have been nothing
more than a relatively jargony you know
kind of thing you know it doesn't that
you don't use them at your will you know
they just they're there to bring your
controlling Elizabeth now you're
controlling Elizabeth but I don't know
do they have it in them to do something
that extraordinary actually 18 tears
meaning if they want to meet
expectations and if they want to tie the
two worlds together that might be a
really interesting and immediate way to
do it as well so Peter any thoughts
before we throw it back to i just i'm
totally confused but i can't wait to see
more yeah i'm i'm confused but i'm
really interested to see where this goes
and in that sense thanks for tuning in
thanks for listening to us jabber on and
on about it thanks for taking a look at
the exclusive look at what appears to be
the opening of episode two of burial at
sea for bioshock infinite and thanks to
everybody for tuning in
you